spoilers lead to anger anger leads to
hate hate leads to suffering people are
going to impressive efforts to spoil the
force awakens for people I'm Dave and
welcome to a GS news update reports are
now coming in that people are using star
wars battlefront to post spoilers about
star wars the force awakens which just
opened in theaters widely on Friday a pc
version of battlefront lets players
create their own unique avatars it's
being the internet some people decided
to change theirs to contain spoil your
content for the new movie I have
personally seen people typing spoilers
for the movie in battle fronts in game
chat as there is no option to hide the
messages sent in game you'll very much
at the mercy of the chat box the console
versions of battlefront for Xbox one and
PlayStation 4 are apparently more
spoiler free although separately claims
are the people going through their
recent players list and sending spoiler
filled messages about the force awakens
all of this is to say be careful out
there in games and everywhere else if
you're trying to avoid the force awakens
spoilers the force awakens is already a
huge hit breaking records domestically
and around the globe for more on the
movie you can check out GameSpot's
spoiler free review so if you see the
force awakens yet what did you think
when you found out that and what about
let us know in the comments below or
find me on Twitter at irregular Dave and
for everything Star Wars stay tuned to
gamespot com